joaquim pueyo bonjour
j'ai eu jean paul garraud bonjour
bonjour merci à tous les deux d'être
avec nous ce matin sur la france pour
parler de la question du pouvoir d'achat
qui est au coeur des préoccupations des
français alors que les gilet jaune on
l'a vu on réinvestit l'hérault points ce
week-end comment vous vous l'observez
cette reprise de mouvement est ce que
vous pouvez craindre une colère qui va
généraliser comme au début du mouvement
d'aidé gilet jaune ou où c'est devenu
différent jean paul garraud
les tensions sont toujours présentes
malheureusement je dirais mais nous
savons bien que l'épidémie de kovy d'un
ami finalement tout ceci un peu en
sommeil mais malheureusement la
politique économique étant toujours le
même malheureusement les les prix des
carburants de toutes les dépenses
contraintes des français sont en flèche
et donc du coup forcément ces tensions
qui existent et sont toujours là
s'ajoute à cela d'autres évènements nous
savons en matière de violences et autres
de délinquance donc tout ceci il ya
malheureusement je dirais pour la france
un cocktail qui est tout à fait explosif
donc il n'ya pas de doute ceci risque de
revenir personne ne l'espère tous les
démocrates évidemment de espère que ceci
n'arrivera pas mais je le crains il ya
des tensions très très forte dans le
pays et bien entendu ce qui est proposé
à quelques mois je dirais de la fin de
ce mandat ne règleront absolument rien
donc nous sommes dans une situation
effectivement explosive nous le savons
bien joaquim pueyo vous vous partagez ce
constat une situation explosive avec le
retour des gis les jaunes ce week end
je ne peux pas je peux pas dire que
c'est une situation explosive simplement
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétude cette
pouvoir d'achat même s'il ya eu des
mesures ont été prises lors de ce
quinquennat pour corriger je pense aux
la taxe d'habitation je pense à l'après
d'activité je pense la garantie jeunes
dont il ya eu des mesures de fête faut
pas le nier non plus alors au niveau
médian dit que le pouvoir d'achat a
légèrement augmenté cependant
effectivement actuellement il ya des
inquiétudes le prix d'essence le
trouvais que citer le prix du gaz même
si gouvernement vient de dire que le
prix du gaz serait bloqué pendant
quelques mois
malgré tout il y aura une augmentation
de 12% et vous avez des ménages
relativement modestes qui sont en
souffrance notamment dans le monde rural
parce que vous avez des déplacements
pour aller au travail et effectivement
on utilise des véhicules donc inquiétude
je sais pas si une explosion il ya des
inquiétudes par rapport au pouvoir
d'achat je pense qu'il faudra mettre en
place des mesures d'accompagnement pour
l'épauler famille ça me paraît
nécessaire même si at effet à mon avis
pour certaines familles c'est pas
suffisant alors on va vous entendre
répondre tout de suite jean paul garraud
mais peut-être avant on va on va voir la
proposition justement fait de jean luc
mélenchon notamment sur la question des
prix de l'énergie on en parlait à
l'instant voyez ces tweets de jean luc
mélenchon
le blocage des prix a déjà été mise en
place par rocard sur l'essence et même
par monsieur macron sur les prix des
masques et du gel hydroalcoolique
c'est ce qu'il faut faire sur l'essence
le gaz et l'électricité dans l'immédiat
il faut bloquer les prix de
l'électricité du gaz et de l'essence est
également augmenter les salaires si ce
n'est pas fait d'ici avril je le ferai
quand j'arriverai au pouvoir en avril
2022 alors jean paul garraud c'est vrai
que le prix du gaz augmente et bloqué
jusqu'au printemps prochain il faut en
faire de même pour les sens comme visuel
explique jean luc mélenchon
mais les blocages ça n'a qu'une valeur
très ponctuel c'est à dire que ce sont
les successeurs qui vont devoir
affronter ce qui va se passer ensuite
donc actuellement nous sommes il faut
quand même pas oublier que monsieur
macron quand il est arrivé au pouvoir a
alourdi les taxes notamment sur les
carburants il y à 60% de taxes donc sur
sur les carburants sur sur l'essence par
exemple il ya 30 % de taxes sur le gaz
il ya 25 % de taxe sur l'électricité et
nous avons même des taxes sur les taxes
la tei cpe cette contribution
énergétique s'ajoute à la tva donc si
vous voulez s'ils ne sont pas les prix
du marché en réalité qui font les
fluctuations et là où il faut agir ce
sont bien entendu sur tout cet axe et
l'état l'état est en charge évidemment
de cet axe tous ces prélèvements
obligatoires dont des dépenses
contraintes alors j'attendais simplement
gens pour des mois donc mon
contradicteur bon qui
faisait état des inquiétudes des
français mais combien c'est pas les
inquiétudes cd réalité ce sont des
réalités j'étais en débat avec une
députée de la république en marche elle
parler de ressenti d'un ressemble qui me
serait comme le sentiment d'insécurité
alors qu'il n'ya pas d'insécurité la
scène reste un ressenti sur le pouvoir
d'achat qui finalement n'est pas si
mauvais que ça puisqu'on a un catalogue
de mesures qui a été mise en place mais
c'est une c'est une c'est une erreur
fondamentale enfin je veux pas être plus
méchant enfin on arrive à la fin d'un
mandat le dit long de monsieur macro et
de son gouvernement est là et nous
savons parfaitement que malheureusement
pour les français avec le racket fiscal
qui l'y a notamment avec tout ce qu'ils
aient toutes les dépenses considérables
que l'on fait donc en matière notamment
évidemment de de tout ce qui touche à
une immigration totalement incontrôlée
si vous voulez c'est tout ceci fait que
ça coûte très très cher à nos
concitoyens il faut leur rendre l'argent
il faut rendre l'argent en français et
on peut faire de très grosses économies
par ailleurs j'entendais monsieur
mélenchon bien sûr qu'ils parleraient
salaires et tout ceci mais on doit faire
un certain nombre d'économies des
dépenses que n'auront plus à faire à nos
concitoyens et à partir de ce moment là
en réintègre dans le circuit finalement
un pouvoir d'achat regardez ce qui s'est
passé même en angleterre qui a réduit
considérablement son immigration et bien
du coup il ya une hausse des salaires il
ya un effet mécanique qui est constaté
donc tout ceci si vous voulez entre les
pressions fiscales inadmissible et
finalement toutes ses mesures qu'il faut
prendre aussi par rapport aux
entreprises par rapport au travail
diminuer l'impôt sur les sociétés
diminué la tva et bien tout ceci est
surtout et surtout lutter contre le
mondialisme si vous voulez parce que ça
ça met en concurrence
nos agriculteurs enfin tout ceci doit
être fait c'est ce que nous proposons ça
va redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français naturellement joaquim pueyo
viens d'entendre jean paul yao qui ne
nous dit finalement et c'est pas inutile
d'augmenter les salaires mais ce qu'il
faut faire c'est davantage baissé les
taxes beaucoup plus de taxes qu'est ce
que vous répondez
écoutez je sais ici c'est quand même pas
si simple que ça je ne sais que monsieur
caroff est apolitique et on en fait tous
simplement moi je constate que
effectivement le l'énergie par exemple
augmentent au niveau des ménages et donc
moi je pense par exemple que les primes
qu'on va la prime et sur l'énergie elle
paraît nécessaire l ai pas eu à l'époque
est il donc je pense qu'il faut
accompagner dot dans l'immédiat je sais
que à long terme ya peut-être une
nouvelle politique que les candidats
pourront proposer mais l'a immédiatement
je pense qu'il ya les accompagnements à
court terme qui me paraissent
nécessaires au niveau d'énergie par
exemple moi je sais qu'en tant que maire
nous avons mis en place un fonds dead
pour des familles qui ont du mal par
exemple à payer leur leur leur
électricité ou leur gasoil conséquent
quand les le chauffage est au gaz oil
malheureusement encore donc il ya des
mesures d'accompagnement c'est ce que je
dis il faut accompagner des familles
est-ce qu'il faut dramatiser le tout ne
pense pas mais le gaz va augmenter
probablement et je pense qu'il ya une
question qui doit se poser par rapport à
l'énergie c'est l'indépendance
énergétique de la france on est trop
liée aux exportations par exemple le gaz
on sait très bien d'où vient le gaz donc
la dépendance énergétique de la france
pour moi c'est fondamental si on veut à
long terme maîtriser les prix d'énergie
parce que l'énergie ce sera
effectivement un problème important pour
notre économie et avec des conséquences
que nous connaissons concernant les sens
on a déjà essayé de bêtes de baisser les
taxes on l'a déjà fait auparavant alors
je pense que si effectivement
l'augmentation continue il faudra pour
le moment agir sur ces taxis on veut
effectivement que les françaises puis
ceux des français puissent utiliser leur
véhicule dans des conditions
optimales parce que je crois dans le
monde rural par exemple la voiture est
nécessaire dans le monde urbain vous
avez les transports en commun on peut
stabiliser les prix des transports en
commun mais quand il s'agit d'augmenter
d'essence et bien c'est compliqué pour
des familles qui vivent dans le monde
rural alors ensuite c'est peut-être une
politique globale par rapport à
l'énergie qui me paraît nécessaire la
dépendance pour moi elle est important
et donc ce qui veut dire une réflexion à
faire sur le mix énergétique sur le
nucléaire je crois faut pas avoir de
tabou sur le nucléaire aux grâce à osny
clair on a une et une indépendance
énergétique
c'est que on est attentif pour le
concernant la sécurité puisque
concernant l'environnement messi
vraiment une politique globale qui sont
peut-être voir au niveau des nuages
c'est mon pote de garoua bon d'accord
finalement sur cette question
d'indépendance énergétique non mais
j'entends leurs contradicteurs qui parle
de cela mais je regrette il soutient un
gouvernement qui a fait une politique
totalement contraire quand on parle
d'indépendance énergétique évidemment
qu'il faut l'indépendance énergétique
évidemment qu'il faut restaurer la
souveraineté
également dans ce domaine en ce qui
concerne la france mais qui a organisé
le pillage d'edf qui qui qui qui ferme
qui veut qui a fermé spéciaux naïm qui
veut arrêter les centrales nucléaires
pour ça pour plaire aux verts et ee pour
plaire à l'union européenne mais c'est
le gouvernement actuel
donc effectivement il faut faire
totalement inverse et nous on est
totalement favorable pour une reprise
d'un programme nucléaire notamment sur
des petites centrales nucléaires
modulaire on est totalement favorable
évidemment pour restaurer les barrages
parts par exemple hydroélectriques il ya
rien de nouveau dans tout ça c'est le
général de gaulle qui l'avait c et e
excusez moi mais le maquereau est en
train de bazarder tout cela pour
satisfaire à une idéologie qu'idéologie
verte verte mais d'une certaine façon si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire ce qui
est surtout militante et surtout
politiques et à l'union européenne on a
on abbas a redit tout cela donc quand je
parle de souveraineté énergétique
évidemment qu'il y à de l'énergie à
l'extérieur on est obligé de la prendre
à l'extérieur puisque nous on est en
train de fiche en l'air excusez moi
notre notre si nos centrales nucléaires
notre énergie décarbonée kiki qu'est
vraiment la plus préservatrice pour
l'environnement tout ceci alors et
maintenant on est dépendant finalement
d'une situation de plus en plus
extérieure dans ce domaine et dans un
autre c'est ça la mondialisation c'est 5
nous contentons nous nous sommes
partisans d'un camp national d'un accord
national pour faire un saut parce qu'on
a des richesses en france alors il faut
arrêter d'aller les chercher ailleurs il
faut il faut pas mettre en concurrence
tout le monde et puis et puis vous allez
voir que la politique économique dont
n'est pas qu'économique
quand on va retrouver de la souveraineté
ça va changer la vie des français alors
pour revenir sur l'augmentation
rapide du pouvoir d'achat pour les
français on a entendu françois bayroux
le haut commissaire au plan
fustigé dans les colonnes du jdd une
surenchère de promesses qui pour lui ne
sont pas réalistes notamment la promesse
de la candidate anne hidalgo regarder
quand madame hidalgo propose le
doublement au moins du salaire des
enseignants donc de tous les salaires et
des retraites de la fonction publique
sans en financer un seul euro et en
annonçant en même temps une baisse des
taxes c'est croire que les électeurs
sont débiles
jeudi mme pilloud quand françois bayrou
s'en prend aux promesses d'anne hidalgo
vous le rejoignez vous répondez quoi
les promesses d'anne hidalgo bon je sais
qu'elles ont été critiqués notamment
lorsqu'un indiqué qu'il fallait doubler
les salaires des enseignants simplement
je crois qu'elle a voulu dire que les
enseignants étaient rémunérés par
rapport à la moyenne européenne qu'il
fallait effectivement faire un effort
alors je ne sais pas si pas les employés
nouveau doublement je pense que les
salaires des enseignants mérite
effectivement une augmentation sur le
moyen terme et ça me paraît peu
nécessaire si on veut attirer
effectivement dans le corps des
enseignants les hommes des femmes ou
savez il ya un problème de recrutement
actuellement dans tous les métiers donc
il est bien évident que si on veut
recruter effectivement les salariés il
faudra probablement joué sur la masse
salariale on le voit dans certains corps
de métier on a du mal à recruter des
cuisiniers
ddd des plombiers des déserteurs
également des certains corps de métier
si en difficulté j'étais au salon
habitat ou des artisans me disent qu'ils
ont des grosses difficultés pour
recruter effectivement des personnels
donc pour jouer ce pouvoir d'achat il
faut jouer se laisse aller à également
je pense qu'il faut mettre en place des
dispositifs pour assiter effectivement
les entreprises augmentent et les
salariés c'est ce qu'a voulu dire je
crois anne hidalgo d'ailleurs la plupart
des candidats le 10 il faudra
probablement augmenter les salaires
notamment pour les ménages les plus
faibles et c'est ça peut jouer ensuite
ce pouvoir d'achat bien évidemment et ça
passe par de l'accompagnement le fait
par exemple de baisser les charges
sociales ça ainsi bien évidemment les
entreprises à embaucher ça me paraît
également importants dans certains corps
de métiers et puis le le le pouvoir
d'achat il n'est pas uniforme en france
vous avez effectivement des dix régions
des métropoles ou pouvoir d'achat plus
important que c'est une région moi
j'habite dans un appartement rue
effectivement le boire d'achat et médian
et il est même plus faible que d'autres
régions donc je crois qu'il faut en
tenir compte également dans les
politiques publiques jean paul garraud
et ce sera ce sera le mot de la fin pour
vous finalement il n'y a pas de baguette
magique que comme le dit le haut
commissaire au plan françois bayroux en
ce qui concerne la hausse des salaires
que témoin mois quand on chante comme
chantôme tout cela je suis quand même
assez stupéfait par ce que tous ces gens
que nous venons d'entendre sont quand
même aux manettes si je puis dire depuis
quand un bon moment 1 depuis que
françois hollande a gagné l'élection
présidentielle en 2012 donc on nous dit
à six mois à six mois de la fin du
mandat de monsieur macron il faut faire
ceci il faut faire ceci il faut faire
ceci enfin il faut être sérieux quoi
voilà maintenant le lard la france ne
peut plus attendre dans ce domaine
économique aidant les autres elle ne
peut plus attendre c'est une question
d'urgence vitale donc le changement de
politique il doit être effectivement
très fort très appuyé c'est ce que nous
proposons nous avons des projets qui
sont clés en main notamment en matière
de pouvoir d'achat marine le pen s'est
exprimée plusieurs fois à ce sujet donc
maintenant il faut passer à autre chose
sont pas quand il faut arrêter de dire
on va écouter bon et on va faire ceci il
faudrait il faudrait le faire oui on
dresse un constat bon voilà on fait des
consultations comme en matière de
justice d'ailleurs les états généraux de
la justice actuellement quelques mois
enfin cinq mois de consultations alors
qu'on termine le mandat dans six mois et
c'est des opérations de com vient de
sortir un plan de 1 nouveau plan de
relance à 1 que de 30 milliards d'euros
qui va être gagée sur la dette 1 qui
s'ajoute à un plan précédent de 56
milliards d'euros enfin qu'est ce que
c'est tout ça en fait du n'importe quoi
donc maintenant il est effectivement
indispensable de changer de politique
nous nous sommes prêts merci à tous les
deux en tout cas d'avoir accepté de
débattre ce matin en direct sur rt
france merci à vous joaquim pueyo maire
ps d'alençon merci à vous jean paul
garraud à député européen